[Música]
una semana más bienvenidos a cultura que
hoy inicia con javier cámara porque
según el actor aunque haya criterio
político y violencia el mundo sí o sí se
sustenta sobre gente buena y héctor abad
gómez a quien interpretan no podía ser
mayor a puerto de bondad para una
colombia en lucha y harta de no tener
paz ya en los 70 de este buen médico y
profesor la situación nacional era igual
en guerra pero con una necesidad de
velar por los derechos humanos de los
colombianos haga como retrato a su hijo
héctor en la obra homónima el olvido que
estaremos no sólo fue pionero en hablar
de salud pública o acceso a agua limpia
sino que en 1987 su defensa de lo justo
le costó su asesinato en medellín sabía
el riesgo pero nunca dejó de preocuparse
por los menos favorecidos
y enseñar he enseñado bien poco
si acaso siempre pretende enseñar a
pensar con libertad
[Música]
de los demás
ningún problema solo de los demás
los paramilitares están haciendo lo que
se les antoja como una fuerza de choque
que pretende doblegar los
[Música]
en este país la vida vale muy poco por
todo dice javier cámara que es de
justicia poética que aquellos que han
intentado hacer el bien tengan un
espacio el por su lado sabía que
encarnar lo y marc a su acento paisa iba
a ser escalar el everest pre cineasta
fernando trueba con guión de su hermano
david trueba ha erigido una cinta para
no olvidarlo ni olvidar casi en forma de
tratado la dignidad la educación y la
belleza esta es el gran evento cinéfilo
del 2021 -con pasó por cannes premio
goya iberoamericano y elenco colombiano
no se lo pierdan ya que te inviten a
hacer una película de un colombiano
ilustre como el sector habar gómez un
hombre que marcó una época tanto él como
tantos otros y tantas otras mujeres que
pelearon contra contra contra el horror
ser una buena persona de ese momento ser
una persona coherente con el discurso
vertebrado siendo crítico con unos y con
otros debía ser muy
como dato extra si bien puede sonar raro
oír a cámara como antioqueño al escritor
héctor abad faciolince su sonrisa le
hace pensar en su padre un héroe que
podría estar incluido entre estos
shoppers del universo cinematográfico
marvel cuyo calendario de la fase 4 no
queríamos obviar sabíamos ciertas fechas
pero confirmado que este noviembre
veremos los eternos de la oscarizada
directora claudia o así como en 2023
habrá tercera de los guardianes de la
galaxia
los siguientes personajes no tiene un
super traje pero son como abad uno ser
west hablamos de los michaels la familia
disfuncional que netflix nos habla de
nuestra desconexión de la realidad y uso
de la tecnología a partir de una parodia
de rebelión de las máquinas se trata de
la comedia más desternillante y creativa
al lograr una reflexión sobre el tiempo
y la unión familiar hecha con nuestro
idioma digital al principio a este ritmo
de colores y memes deja un poco
alucinado pero cada referencia desde wes
anderson a doc de pop y los forme y
contribuye al mejor humor apocalíptico
teniendo además aún es natural
protagonista queer
[Aplausos]
bueno
ya de lleno en el patrimonio y el arte
también en 2023 se podrá disfrutar de un
renovado coliseo con una arena retráctil
que no solo transportará a los combates
de gladiadores y fieras sino que
permitirá ver las galerías subterráneas
hoy en gran parte al aire libre el
proyecto sostenible y con coordinación
de la unesco busca protegerlas así como
dotar de un suelo al anfiteatro flavio
de cara a futuros espectáculos mientras
que en parís un colectivo de artistas
migrantes residentes del aceite at an
national des deux desarrollará hasta
julio una muestra dedicada a la historia
y sobre apropiación la si te lleva
acogiendo a creadores internacionales
desde 1965 pero ahora estos lidian con
los ecos de los conflictos pasados de
sus tierras
juntando pequeños fragmentos de historia
con paciencia y meticulosidad una foto
de un rostro un paisaje todo para dar un
sentido de humanidad de los conflictos
en sus países de origen así lo cuentan
un grupo de artistas de siria república
democrática del congo y argelia con un
mosaico de fotos la directora
franco-argelina katia camelli regresa
argelia poscolonial muy alejada de las
narrativas contadas por los políticos
para mí la historia es una ficción a
partir de ciertos hechos siempre hay un
narrador detrás de la historia a veces
es un historiador otra es una figura
política entonces desde el momento en
que hay una narración hay una forma de
ficción y así a través de las imágenes
también podemos cuestionarnos a nosotros
mismos y recrear su historia en la cita
internacional de sharp objetos
cotidianos adquieren formas simbólicas
para los artistas es una forma de
denunciar la violencia del pasado y el
presente impactado por las imágenes del
arresto de shorts floyd en eeuu el
artista etíope jacob business recrea el
asesinato del afroamericano a manos de
un policía blanco
decidí usar este adoquín también para
recordar la historia de los franceses
que vivieron en mayo de 1968 lo usé como
símbolo de la violencia policial para
denunciar la injusticia que reina en
este mundo los artistas residentes en la
cita internacional de sharp recibirán a
los visitantes cuando los museos vuelvan
a abrir en francia a partir del 19 de
mayo
de regreso a latinoamérica y ya esa
colombia de protesta inmortalizada en el
28 de abril la orquesta filarmónica de
bogotá quiso transmitirle unión y
solidaridad desde la calle y con lo que
mejor se hace oír la música
cuando desde brasil todos nos imaginamos
la combinación río de janeiro y favelas
pero es contra el trap de cría o cosecha
que al estilo de atlanta varios quieren
evocar nos lo real de estos barrios lo
hacen con armas de verdad con escenario
marginal no por capricho sino porque la
clase trabajadora se mezcla con narcos y
pandillas un cotidiano en el que vitor
oliveira ha alzado un estudio musical
mientras otros luchan entre el arte y la
policía que cree que eso y no el día a
día es una glorificación de la violencia
gracias por su compañía y cuídense
muchas gracias
las tentaciones
[Música]